si toutes les fractures de notre pays ne
sont pas apparus avec vous vos décisions
et votre arrogance collective ont
contribué à toutes les aggraver si le
président veut s'intéresser à l'histoire
il doit la regarder des deux côtés et
arrêter de sélectionner entre les
mémoires mais une nouvelle fois il a
choisi ce qui se sont battus contre la
france comment votre gouvernement
informé à l'avancé at il pu laisser
détruire un monument historique se
rendant juridiquement complice par
abstention d'un délit puni de 10 ans de
prison secteur culturel et l'industrie
du spectacle fondu de très nombreux
métiers qui sont aujourd'hui très
gravement menacées comme le minutes je
me bats depuis cinq ans sur le sujet des
squats on avait déposé une proposition
de loi qui est débattu ici rejeté par la
majorité actuelle oui il nous faut
soutenir son fine aux forces de l'ordre
parce qu'ils sont eux aussi nos héros du
quotidien et parce qu'il n'ya pas de
liberté sans sécurité pas d'état de
droit sans ordre républicain renoncement
à combattre le communautarisme
islamistes renoncement à rompre avec le
laxisme pénale de madame taubira
renoncement à construire les 15000
places de prisons profit ce renoncement
à placer en rétention de sûreté les
djihadistes sortie de prison pourquoi ne
prenez-vous pas la décision d'expulser
tous les étrangers est radicalisée de
notre territoire comme le député les
républicains l'avaient proposer par voie
d'amendement le mal est profond et
inquiétant en de multiples endroits de
notre pays l'école est désormais
atteinte par le danger du
communautarisme aggravée par le
radicalisme religieux votre gouvernement
vante souvent les mérites de son action
pour améliorer le pouvoir d'achat des
français
pourtant ces mêmes français nous ont dit
au cours de ces dernières semaines que
ce n'était pas vrai la vérité c'est
qu'en surtaxant les carburants vous
faites marcher la pompe à fric
dans cette affaire l'état prélève dix
fois plus que ce qu'il ne reversent
l'alimentation est une des clés pour
répondre aux défis qui se dressent
devant nous bien manger c'est la santé
pour tous bien produire c'est agir sur
l'environnement bien transformer ces
soutenir notre industrie quand allez
vous cesser de malmener nos agriculteurs
qui ont l'amour du métier qui
nourrissent la france et dont nous avons
besoin vous avait étouffé fessenheim au
bénéfice du dogme et au détriment de
l'environnement les français n'attendent
pas d'être bluffé ou discret sur des
plateaux de télévision
ils attendent des actes
[Musique]